grazie mille bravissimo avere piaciuta
molto cool turista curioso non vi ha
detto
cosa più importanti ve ne siete accorti
sono un non vedente questo è
fondamentale per voi perché arrivati a
questo punto uno può aver voglia di un
caffè è il momento cioè lo speaker non
vedente permette di uscire andare a
prendere il caffè tranquillamente solo
una cosa vi chiedo ultimo che va via se
mi avvisi allora iniziamo iniziano
questa questo inizio mi serviva un
pochettino per esorcizzare il momento
perché non vi vedo ma fate paura lo
stesso è una casa big data intelligenza
collettiva quando ho saputo il tema del
miu miu vento mi sono un pochettino
spaventato stiamo parlando di ricerche
di frontiera e dell'informatica e della
matematica come ri come riuscirò in 15
minuti
a presentarle in modo tale da non
spaventare ho deciso di farlo
raccontando vele veramente come con come
le ho capite io ero ancora sono passati
parecchi anni ero neoassunto e in un
viaggio di trasferimento di lavoro c'era
lo stess molto simpatica che va
accompagnato al posto sull'aereo a un
certo punto mi ha detto posso darle
qualcosa da legge faccia qualcosa la
legge sono non vede però lo diceva in
maniera c'era qualcosa era molto
orgogliosi posso darle un giornale in
braille
certo passiamo negli stati uniti
d'america un cieco il giornale bright
subito dopo ho capito che tutto il mondo
è paese perché ho messo ci hanno dato un
occhio alla data meglio il dito sulla
data il giornale alla di quattro anni
prima ma vabbè sono anche appassionato
di storia l'ho preso e effettivamente
però ho fatto bene perché ho incontrato
un articolo che era di 4 anni prima era
coerente ovviamente con la data del
giornale però che mi era sfuggito forse
all'epoca che stava raccontando una cosa
che io iniziavo l'avventura nel mondo
informatico e quell'articolo mi ha
subito messo in
uguali era la storia di un ragazzo che
si era laureato in fisica con una tesi
su come costruire una bomba atomica in
una scatola da scarpe come una bomba
atomica in una scatola da scarpe ma ero
incuriosito sono andato a vedere il
ragazzo diceva che tutta la ricerca gli
era costata 8 dollari spesi su internet
faccio ma certo mancava il combustibile
l'uranio arricchito ma quanto può
costare l'uranio arricchito non ne idee
un milione 10 milioni di euro
avete idea di quanta gente qua fuori
dispone di 10 milioni di euro e di 8
dollari e la bomba atomica è una bomba
atomica
la domanda spontanea era ma chi è
l'idiota che ha scritto su internet come
costruire una bomba atomica è stata la
risposta che col tempo dato a questa
domanda che mi ha veramente spaventato
perché quell'idiota non esiste internet
è l'ipertesto è il testo impotenza è il
libro che contiene tutti i libri alle
mie spalle vedete scorrere una pagina
bellissima una delle pagine più belle
della letteratura mondiale quella in cui
borges spiega la biblioteca di babele e
in basso vedete questo scorrere di
questo libro lì c'è tutto è solo
questione di tempo e appare qualunque
cosa questo è l'ipertesto questo
internet questo è tim berners lee questo
è tutto quanto riguarda oggi il modello
culturale attenzione ma c'è qualcosa in
più cioè la potenza informatica e
matematica di questo strumento
oggi è incredibile ed è il big data e
qualcosa di piu dell'ipertesto
ovviamente voi pensate il libro che
contiene tutti i libri certo è
facilissimo pensare che prima o poi in
quella riga che vedete in basso appaiano
i promessi sposi la divina commedia
pinocchio promessi sposi un libro a caso
quel ramo del lago di como che volge al
mezzogiorno dove vanno i big data
beh quel ramo del lago
como che volge a mezzogiorno alla parola
quelle segue la parola ramo quante volte
nel romanzo e alla parola ramo segue la
parola dell quante volte nel romanzo e
se io chiedessi oggi a un computer di
permuta per mutare parolaccia matematica
tremendo di scambiare tra loro di posto
tutte le parole ma non casualmente
cambiandole di posto
rispettando la distribuzione la
percentuale delle coppie delle terne per
un computer è questione veramente di
poco tempo
ma vi rendete conto che costruisco un
libro partendo da un altro libro è il
sogno di borges entrare nella biblioteca
di babele e non perdere la ragione io è
un pò che sto cercando i numeri del
superenalotto di settimana prossima ci
sono acp che quello che ti farai
ed è proprio eco
ma andiamo un pochettino oltre a questo
concetto il big data
effettivamente va un pochettino al di là
pensate quel ramo del lago di como che
volge al mezzogiorno quel in quanti modi
può essere tradotto in cinese ramo in
quanti modi può essere tradotto in
cinese e poi www.facebook.com entro in
un social network in cina e vado a
cercare tra quanto scrivono i cinesi
frasi che hanno la stessa distribuzione
percentuale della traduzione cinese
delle parole del romanzo ottengo una
traduzione non matematica non da un
linguista ma una traduzione è legata da
quella che si chiama intelligenza
collettiva chiedo se poi possibile
passare a lucido successivo questo
lucido richiede un attimino devo
lasciarlo lì un pochettino perché
richiede un momento per poterlo per
poter acquisire perché perché lo capiamo
questo lucido questa questa frase la
capiamo e la frase famosissima
ovviamente di solito a me serve per
sottolineare che cosa c'è l'elemento
fondamentale che c'è dietro a questo
lucido al fatto che noi riusciamo a
leggerlo in virtù di non sto neanche a
cercare di elencarvi le capacità che
sottendono a questa acqua questo
strumento
sta di fatto che tutto questo e va sotto
il concetto di intelligenza naturale e
l'informatica da sempre ha cercato di
emularla attraverso i concetti per
quelli più di voi che sono un pochettino
vicini per money informatiche hanno
senz'altro sentito parlare di
intelligenza artificiale bene i big data
si basano invece su un altro modello di
intelligenza cioè quello che c'è dietro
questo lucido può essere di gran lunga
cercare di emularne il comportamento
matematico è difficile è facilissimo
attraverso proprio l'intelligenza
collettiva l'intelligenza collettiva il
fatto di andare nei social network
andare in rete raccogliere questa
centina in quantità infinita di dati che
scorrono le telecamere le trasmissioni
televisive le e mail e gli sms sono
tutta una serie di informazioni che
forniscono uno strumento di elaborazione
potentissimo proprio sulla base di
questa contengono delle regole d'uso che
permettono a un algoritmo matematico di
ricostruire la stessa abilità con cui
oggi percepite questo lucido e questo
non è vero solo per il linguaggio
parlato è vero anche per il linguaggio
per voi pensate che cos'è un brano
musicale un filmato non solo sequenza di
lettere sono comunque sequenze di serie
d1 quindi nella biblioteca di babele ci
sono anche tutti i film che sono stati
girati e tutti i film che verranno
girati domani ma posso pensare pensare
al gli aidoru cioè questi cantanti
virtuali che in pubblicità costruiscono
velocemente
prendendo come ispirazione ma come
ispirazione matematica analisi
percentuale della distribuzione dei bit
le cantanti del rock star del momento
permettono di costruire a costi
bassissimi jingles pubblicitari
pensate a un'altra componente importante
tutto questo c'è dietro il comportamento
di quel ragazzo che si muoveva a caso su
internet bene oggi i nostri ragazzi
avete senz'altro sentito parlare dei
makers non si muovono a caso su internet
si muovono a caso in un internet
l'area internet che potenza la realtà in
realtà potenziata fino a poco tempo fa
quando dovevo stampare un documento sul
mio bel computer prendevo il mouse
spostavo l'icona del documento sulla
stampante bottone destro e produceva la
stampa del documento
oggi sto leggendo la sms appoggio il
telefono sulla stampante e il mouse
diventa la mia mano ma voi pensate
questo meccanismo fatto su internet da
migliaia di ragazzi che disegnano pezzi
componenti li inviano poter dire
stampanti 3d molto diversi
molto di più ci sono vera e propria
fabbrica luci spenti con strumenti che
sono in grado di
tecnicamente si chiama flottare ma
ritagliare nel metallo nel legno
stampare in tre dimensioni con le
polvere ceramiche con le polveri e fibre
di vetro ricostruire tutto questo è
veramente costruire un internet che non
è fatta col mouse ma è fatta veramente
nella vita nella realtà in cui siamo
immersi tutti i giorni e il problema
grosso enorme che salta fuori
lo sapete tutti lo vedete
tranquillamente anche sui giornali
questi giorni ma la riservatezza cosa
c'è dietro tutto questo bene qua è
difficile accettarlo ma è un po il
messaggio in generale la tecnologia e
violenza così come violenta la cultura
con la cultura io recupero spazio ma lo
tolga un altro è un equilibrio che si
stabilisce e questa cosa è spiegata
molto bene nei testi di sociologia cioè
come la
tecnologia per violento e come tale può
essere veramente trasformato in qualità
di vita con l'intelligenza con
intelligenza collettiva in una
barzelletta che circola tra i banchi di
sociologia
qualche maligno dice che circa anche tre
banchi politici alla barzelletta di un
vecchietto che scrive al figlio che è
stato messo in prigione che gli dice ma
cosa hai fatto sciagurato ti sei fatto
arrestare adesso devo dissodare l'orto
non ho l'energia come faccio a farlo
arriva la risposta del figlio papà papà
non toccare l'orto c'è la refurtiva
subito dopo arrivano la polizia che
butta per aria tutto l'orto arriva la
lettera del papa fa caro papà data la
situazione attuale era l'unico modo che
avevo per aiutarti a dissodare loro